what would happen if the death penalty
just disappeared in the US the
government could continue executions of
the roughly 3,000 inmates currently
sentenced to death or retroactive Lee
sentence them to life without parole
instead from a financial standpoint this
will make a lot of sense death row
inmates require stricter security that
cost more money
and since prisoners can remain on death
row for decades that adds up States
would also save money on prosecution's
death penalty cases can cost up to 10
times more than others so it's cheaper
but shouldn't serious criminals pay the
ultimate price
perhaps but since 1973 more than 150
people on death row were eventually
found innocent prisoners wait years even
decades for execution not knowing when
or if it will come and recently changes
and drugs used for lethal injection have
resulted in gruesomely botched
executions some prisoners have chosen
not to appeal their cases to shorten the
time they have to spend on death row but
doesn't the death penalty deter crime
actually murder rates in states without
the death penalty have remained lower
than states which have it the death
penalty is also disproportionately
applied to minority offenders so no
death penalty might mean a little more
equality in the justice system a lot of
money saved and more time for
prosecutors to try other cases 32 states
still execute their prisoners and lethal
injection is the poison of choice but
European countries who abolished the
death penalty